glad the suspense is over in that
category I was on pins and needles now
to uh to present the awards for best
short subjects to stars who began acting
at the ages of 5 and 10 and between them
they have 37 years experience you figure
it out here they are Carol Lynley and
Bobby Benson
okay may I just tell you that it's
really a pleasure to be here with you
oh well Ravi you certainly can thank you
and you certainly may because we're
going to double our pleasure because we
have two awards to present tonight and
the first one is for Best Animated Short
subject the nominees are
oh my darling Nico krama producer Rip
Van Winkle Will Vinton producer special
delivery
Eunice McAuley and John Weldon producers
and the winner is the winner is special
delivery
Eunice McAuley and John Rogan producers
this is absolutely incredible thank you
to the Academy and I'd like to say that
this is the 40th anniversary of the
National Film Board of Canada and we'd
like to say happy birthday to them and
we're bringing you a present home and
I'd like to also thank all our fellow
animators out there is just great to be
so part of such a terrific group thank
you very much
for outstanding achievement in
live-action short films the nominees are
a different approach Jim Belcher and
fern field producers Mandy's grandmother
Andrew Sugarman producing strange fruit
Seth pence co-producer a teenage father
Taylor Hackford producer and the winner
is teenage father Taylor Hackford
producer
some marvelous surprise I have to thank
the many talented people who contributed
to teenage father are marvelous cast
especially Timothy weed and Susanne crow
our cinematographer Robbie Greenberg
editor
Sally Corrine Lisa rich Andrea's mo my
wife Lynn and my son Ryo for their
continuing support in love and
especially the executive producer
Charlotte dearmond and the Children's
Home Society of California who sponsored
this film who went out and surveyed the
high schools talked to the students and
found out that they wanted a film about
teenage fathers we tried to present an
honest picture of the problems that
these young men and women face in a very
difficult situation hopefully we
succeeded thank you
you